CAMPAIGN.
SEAN?
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT,
TREY YINGST, THAT A SAD
COMMENTARY.
GOT TO PRAY FOR THE PEOPLE IN
UKRAINE.
WE GO TO BILL HEMMER TONIGHT, A
LOT GOING ON, WHAT IS THE
LATEST?
>> SEAN, GOOD EVENING TO YOU.
STUNNING REPORT BY TREY, TRY TO
ZOOM IN ON A LITTLE OF WHAT TREY
WAS DESCRIBING, THREE STORIES,
TWO IN THE SOUTH AND IN KYIV THE
CAPITAL CITY AND THE NORTH IS A
THIRD STORY.
THE TOWN OF MARIUPOL THAT TREY
WAS JUST TALKING ABOUT IT, THEY
HAVE BEEN POUNDED FOR THREE
DAYS, SEAN, AND SOME OF THE
VIDEO HERE THAT WE HAVE SEEN ON
THE INSIDE OF THE CITY HERE,
TAKEN FIRE FROM THE SEA OF OFF,
TAKEN FIRE FROM THE LAND, AS
WELL, ASK YOURSELF, WHY IS THIS
SO IMPORTANT TO THE RUSSIAN
ARMY?
YOU THINK ABOUT, PUTIN WENT INTO
THE DON BASS REGION EIGHT YEARS
AGO AND TOOK HALF OF IT.
IF THE RUSSIAN MILITARY THAT
CAME OUT OF OUT OF CRIMEA ABOUT
NINE DAYS AGO ON A BEE LINE UP P
TO MARIUPOL, IF THEY CAN SECURE
THE CITY, THE LAND BRIDGE THAT
STARTS TO COME DOWN IN A MOMENT
HERE, LIKE A CRESCENT AT THE
BOTTOM PART OF THE COUNTRY, THAT
IS ONE ASPECT OF THE STORY, THE
OTHER IS TO THE LEFT PAST THE
CITY OF KHERSON.
RUSSIAN FORCES HAVE